>>> FOR JUST SEE IT FOR YOURSELF
EVIDENCE OF THE HATE AND BIGOTRY
IN THE REPUBLICAN RANKS.
AT THE CENTER OF THE LATEST
EPISODE IS COLORADO
CONGRESSWOMAN LAUREN BOEBERT.
ONE VIDEO CLIP OF HER RACISM AND
ISLAMOPHOBIA SURFACED OVER THE
WEEKEND AND HER EFFORT TO QUIET
THAT STORM DID NOT GO WELL TO
PUT IT MILDLY.
SHE WAS RECORDED, YOU SEE IT
THERE, TALKING ABOUT HOW SHE WAS
NERVOUS TO BE ON THE ELEVATOR
WITH ILHAN OMAR IMPLYING SHE WAS
A TERRORIST.
SHE DID NOT APOLOGIZE AND OMAR
ENDED THE CONVERSATION BECAUSE
IT WAS NOT PRODUCTIVE.
AN ADDITIONAL VIDEO UNCOVERED
TURNS OUT.
SHE TOLD THIS STORY BEFORE.
THIS IS FROM A SEPTEMBER
FUND-RAISER WHO TELLS HER
ELEVATOR STORY AND ALSO CALLS
OMAR AND ANOTHER MUSLIM OF
CONGRESS BLACK-HEARTED AND EVIL.
>> ONE OF MY STAFFERS ON HIS
FIRST DAY WITH ME GOT INTO AN
ELEVATOR IN THE CAPITOL, AND
IN -- IN THAT ELEVATOR WE WERE
JOINED BY ILHAN OMAR.
IT WAS JUST US IN THERE AND I
SAID LOOK IT THERE, THERE'S THE
JIHAD SQUAD.
>> LET'S BRING IN ANDREW
KACZENSKI, THE LEADER OF THE
KFILE WHO BROKE THIS STORY.
ONE OF THE VALUE OF THIS
FANTASTIC DIGGING BY YOUR TEAM
IS YOUR EYES AND EARS DON'T LIE.
WE SEE HER FOR WHAT SHE IS AND
WHAT SHE BELIEVES.
LET'S LISTEN TO A LITTLE BIT
MORE.
>> WE HAVE ILHAN OMAR AND
RASHANDA TALIB, BLACK-HEARTED
EVIL WOMEN WHO WANT TO DESTROY.
TELL US MORE ABOUT WHAT YOU
FOUND.
YOU JUST HEAR THEY ARE
BLACK-HEARTED EVIL WOMEN.
>> YEAH, RIGHT.
>> I GUESS BECAUSE THEY ARE
MUSLIM.
>> YEAH, YOU KNOW, WE SPOKE
ABOUT THIS IN YOUR INTRO, YOU
KNOW.
THIS IS THE SECOND TIME IN WHICH
SHE HAS MADE THESE COMMENTS.
THE STORY WHERE SHE JOKES THAT
ILHAN OMAR IS A TERRORIST
BASICALLY.
SHE NOTABLY TELLS -- IT'S
BASICALLY THE SAME STORY THAT
SHE TOLD IN THE EVENTS THAT WENT
VIRAL LAST WEEK, YOU KNOW.
SHE CLAIMS OMAR HAD -- DIDN'T
HAVE A BACKPACK SO SHE FELT SAFE
IMPLYING THAT ANY MUSLIM PERSON
WITH A BACKPACK IS A TERRORIST,
AND, YOU KNOW, OMAR'S PEOPLE
HAVE SAID THIS STORY IS A
FABRICATION.
THEY WEREN'T IN AN ELEVATOR
TOGETHER.
I MESSAGED WITH OMAR WHO SAID
THAT, YOU KNOW, BOEBERT IS
UNHINGED AND, YOU KNOW, NOTE
BLITT STORY IS A LITTLE
DIFFERENT FROM LAST TIME.
THERE'S NO CAPITOL HILL POLICE
OFFICER CONFUSING HER AS A
TERRORIST SO IT DOES LEND
CREDENCE TO THE FACT THAT THIS
IS A MADE-UP STORY THAT SHE'S
TELLING A CROWD, I DON'T KNOW,
FOR LAUGHS MAYBE.
I GUESS THE JOKE IS THAT MUSLIMS
ARE TERRORISTS, BUT, YEAH, I
MEAN, LIKE I SAID, OMAR CALLED
THIS UNHINGED.
>> ANDREW KNZKY, GRATEFUL FOR
YOUR REPORTING.
LET'S BRING IT BACK INTO THE
ROOM.
THE POINT THAT ANDREW MAKES IT'S
NOT ONE VIDEO.
IT'S NOT SOMEONE WHO GOT CAUGHT
UP IN THE EMOTION OF A CROWD AND
SAID SOMETHING HORRIBLE AND THEN
TRIES TO APOLOGIZE FOR AND DOES
APOLOGIZE FOR IT.
THIS IS CLEARLY SOMETHING THAT'S
PART OF HER QUOTE, UNQUOTE
ROUTINE.
SHE THINKS IT'S FUNNY.
THIS IS FROM CONGRESSWOMAN OMAR.
I GRACIOUSLY ACCEPTED A CALL
FROM LAUREN BOEBERT.
INSTEAD OF APOLOGIZING FOR
ISLAMOPHOBIC LIES, SHE CONTINUED
ON IN THE CONVERSATION.
>> KEVIN McCARTHY URGED BOEBERT
TO CALLOW MAR.
HE WANTED THIS TO GO AWAY.
BUT IT'S NOT.
>> WE SAW THE TRUE COLORS IN A
VIDEO WHERE SHE DOUBLED DOWN ON
HER REMARKS.
CLEARLY SHE'S NOT SORRY, BUT YOU
DO SEE KEVIN McCARTHY TRY TO PUT
OUT THE FIRES BEHIND THE SCENE
AND URGED A MEETING BETWEEN
INHALLOW MAR AND LAUREN BOEBERT
AND ALSO HAS HAD A CALL RECENTLY
WITH MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE.
HE'S TRYING TO TELL THEM NOT TO
ATTACK THOSE IN THE PARTY AND
WHAT YOU HEAR FROM SOME
MODERATES IN THE PARTY IS YES,
WE UNDERSTAND THAT McCARTHY IS
IN A TOUGH POSITION POLITICALLY
BUT THERE'S A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
POLITICS AND DOING WHAT'S RIGHT
AND CALLING OUT THIS RHETORIC
HAS NO PLACE IN THE PARTY.
>> UNLESS THEY STOP AND UNLESS
THEY APOLOGIZE THEY WILL NOT BE
WELCOME, THEY WON'T HAVE
COMMITTEE ASSIGNMENTS AND WE
DON'T CARE IF WE GET THE
MAJORITY OR NOT BECAUSE
PRINCIPLE IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN
POWER, A CASE MADE BY NOT JUST
ME BUT ONE OF HIS FELLOW
REPUBLICANS.
>> WHEN YOU'RE IN A POSITION OF
LEADERSHIP YOU HAVE TO STAND UP
AND HAVE TO DEAL WITH IT.
I APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT KETCH
CALLED OUR COLLEAGUE DIRECTLY
AND DISCUSSED THE MATTER WITH
HER, BUT AT SOME POINT IN TIME
YOU HAVE TO STAND UP AND CALL IT
OUT FOR WHAT IT IS.
THIS TYPE OF RHETORIC CANNOT BE
CONDONED.
IT CAN NOT BE UPHELD.
>> THE QUESTION IS WILL LEADER
McCARTHY EVER LISTEN TO PEOPLE
LIKE THAT.
YOU CAN GOING TO SAY GIVE US THE
MAJORITY.
GIVE US THE POWER TO WRITE THE
BUDGET AND HAVE A LOT OF CONTROL
AND GIVE US THE POWER TO REIN IN
JOE BIDEN AND WE WELCOME
EXTREMISM IN OUR RANKS.
>> EARLIER THIS YEAR WHEN
MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE MADE HER
OWN STATEMENTS, HE AND SCALISE
PUT OUT STATEMENTS AT LEAST
SAYING, IS YOU KNOW, WE DON'T
CONDONE THIS VIOLENT RHETT RING.
YOU DON'T SEE THAT ANYMORE.
YOU SEE THEM MUCH MORE DEFENSIVE
OF THEIR OWN MEMBERSHIP AND KIND
OF JUST LETTING THIS PLAY OUT.
YOU TRY IT ASK THEM WHAT DO YOU
THINK OF THIS?
ARE YOU GOING TO DO SOMETHING
AND WHY DON'T DEMOCRATS PUNISH
SOME OF THEM OWN, NEVER USING
HIS NAME AND SUGGESTING THAT SHE
HERSELF HAS MADE REMARKS.
>> TOM REED, CONSERVATIVE NANCY
MACE OF SOUTH CAROLINA SAID SHE
FOUND IS REPREHENSIBLE.
SHE GOT THIS FROM MARJORIE
TAYLOR GREENE WHO LOVES TO STIR
THIS STUFF.
NANCY MACE IS THE TRASH IN THE
GOP CONFERENCE.
NEVER ATTACKED BY DEMOCRATS OR
RINOs.
MACE CAN BACK OFF, HANG UP YOUR
REAL GAL PALS, JIT HAD -- I'M
NOT GOING TO REFEET ALL AND SHE
GOES ON WITH MY IPHONE YEAH,
MORE RACISM, AND NANCY MACE
FIRES BACK.
I'M CORRECTING YOU, I'M A
PRO-LIFE FISCAL CONSERVATIVE AND
WHAT I'M NOT IS NOT A BIGOT AND
YOU MIGHT WANT TO TRY THAT OUT
IN YOUR LITTLE LEAGUE.
>> THE THING IS, YES, YOU HAVE
LAUREN BOEBERT AND MARJORIE
TAYLOR GREENE, BUT YOU ALSO HAVE
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP.
I REMEMBER BEING AT RALLIES WITH
TRUMP WHERE HE WOULD JUST PUT UP
ILHAN OMAR'S FACE AND THE CROWD
WOULD GO CRAZY SCREAMING DISH
WAS AT RALLY WHERE HE SAID THAT
OMAR SHOULD GO BACK TO WHERE SHE
CAME FROM, SO THIS IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT IS COMING JUST
FROM THESE KINDS OF FRINGE
MEMBERS.
THIS CAME FROM THE LEADER OF THE
PARTY WHO NEVER APOLOGIZED FOR
ANY OF THOSE THINGS THAT HE
SAID.
>> LET'S BE CLEAR HERE AS WELL.
THIS KIND OF RHETORIC AND
BEHAVIOR ISN'T JUST HAPPENING
BECAUSE OF THE INACTION AND
SILENCE OF THE REPUBLICAN
LEADERS LIKE KEVINMAN CAR THINK
TODAY.
IT'S BECAUSE OF THEIR INACTION
AND SILENCE DURING PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S TIME IN OFFICE AND WHILE
HE WAS CAMPAIGNING FOR
PRESIDENT, WHEN HE WAS TALKING
ABOUT BANNING MUSLIMS FROM THE
COUNTRY.
WHEN HE WAS MAKING INCENDIARY
REMARKS ABOUT CHARLOTTESVILLE,
FOR EXAMPLE, ALL OF THOSE THINGS
ADD UP TO A PATTERN THAT MAKES
THIS KIND OF BEHAVIOR AND KIND
OF RHETORIC OKAY AND ALSO
POLITICALLY ADVANTAGEOUS FOR
THESE MEMBERS WITH THE
REPUBLICAN BASE, AND PEOPLE LIKE
MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE AND
LAUREN BOEBERT ARE PULLING RIGHT
FROM THE TRUMP PLAYBOOK AND
KEVIN McCARTHY HASN'T CHANGED.
>> IT PAYS TO BE EXTREME IN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
>> KEVIN McCARTHY IS AFRAID OF
MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE.
LET'S LAY IT OUT THERE.
HE'S AFRAID SHE WILL GO TO
DONALD TRUMP AND SAY BLOCK HIM
FROM BECOMING A SPEAKER.
IF MORE PEOPLE SPEAK OUT, DOES
THE OTHER MATH BECOME TRUE?
AT SOME POINT WILL KEVIN
McCARTHY HAVE TO MAKE A CHOICE.
>> THAT'S WHAT I'M STARTING TO
HEAR FROM MODERATES BEHIND THE
SCENES.
THEY ARE LESS WILLING TO GO ON
THE RECORD BUT THEY ARE SAYING
YOU COULD HAVE A PROBLEM WITH US
IF HE TAKES US FOR GRANTED AND
THERE ARE MORE US THAN THERE ARE
MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENES IN THE
CONFERENCE.
THERE'S A BALANCING ACT, HE'S
CAUGHT BETWEEN MAJORITY MAKERS
WHO HE HOPES WILL DELIVER HIM
THE MAJORITY AND THE TRUMP
ALLIES THAT CAN MAKE OR